nos amis
photographes qui n'ont plus de pellicule
dans leurs appareils c'est
fini numérique monsieur Président je
sais
oui je sais madame de La gterie mais
vous
savez il a du bon l'ancien monde
parfois mer il sont merci monieur pardon
merci bien chers collègues monsieur le
ministre chers collègues nous sommes
donc ce soit rassemblé pour évoquer dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finance le
budget de la justice dans toutes ces
dimensions j'allais dire et comme il est
d'usage on vous laisse la parole tout de
suite monsieur le ministre avant que nos
rapporteurs et autres collègues aent
l'intention d'intervenir merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs pour
avis mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs bon bon je peux pas vous le
cacher plus longtemps je suis très
heureux monsieur le Président de vous
retrouver pour la 4e année consécutive
sur le projet de budget du ministère de
la
Justice al pour 2024 cet exercice
s'inscrit dans un contexte tout à fait
particulier puisque le Sénat a adopté
définitivement la loi d'orientation et
de programmation pour la justice et je
veux ici vous en remercier à nouveau
cette loi permet de de
iser les hausses de moyens pour
renforcer notre justice en la rendant
c'est évidemment l'objectif et il est
ambitieux plus proche plus protectrice
et plus
rapide pardon pour chacun de nos
concitoyen l'enjeu pour moi aujourd'hui
d'abord de vous démontrer comment
concrètement le gouvernement tient les
engagement qu'il a pris devant vous et
devant les
Français le budget le projet de budget
2024 merci monsieur le Président pour le
ministère de la Justice respecte donc à
la lettre la trajectoire budgétaire que
nous donne la loi de programmation
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la République et à la volonté de la
première ministre et grâce au soutien du
ministre délégué des comptes publics
l'ambition de ce nouveau budget est
d'abord d'améliorer la qualité de la
justice qui doit être rendue au
justiciable venant s'ajouter à des
années d'augmentation et ont permis au
budget du ministère de passer de
6,9 milliards d'euros en 2017 à
9,6 milliards d'euros en 2023 la hausse
se poursuivra en
2024 sans se payer de mots je pense que
l'on peut dire que c'est historique le
projet de budget de la justice que je
vous soumets dépasse la barre symbolique
des 10 milliards d'euros pour atteindre
10,1 milliards d'euros et entre 2023 et
et
2024 ça représente une hausse de près
d'un demi mililliard d'euros
supplémentairire
503 million d'euros très précisément
soit près de
5,3 %
d'augmentation rien que pour les
rémunérations versées aux agents du
ministère hors cotisation retraite
l'enveloppe passera de
4,7 milliards en 2023 à 5, 1 milliard en
2024 soit une hausse parmi les plus
importantes qu'a connu le ministère de
près de 8 % c'est la traduction directe
et concrète de la politique de
ressources humaines des recrutement
massif conjugué à une forte
revalorisation des rémunérations le défi
de ce ministère pour les 4 années à
venir ne sera pas de savoir si nous
allons recruter mais plutôt de savoir
comment nous allons
réussir à pourvoir la totalité des
nouveaux emplois que nous allons créer
d'où l'importance à côté des
recrutements que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
d'annoncer de renforcer évidemment
l'attractivité des métiers de justice je
rappelle qu'au terme de la loi de
programmation en
2027 le budget du ministère frôlera
pardon les les 11 milliards soit une
hausse de près de 60 % dans détail ces
moyens importants permettront
d'alimenter chacune des grandes
composantes du ministère pour lesquelles
les hausse annuelle de crédit hors
cotisation retraite évolueront de la
manière
suivante plus 12 % pour les services
judiciaires pour atteindre 3,8 milliards
d'euros en 2024 contre
3,4 milliards d'euros en
2023 et depuis mon arrivée en 2 20 le
budget des services judiciaires aura
connu une hausse d'environ 30
%. 2è point stabilisation du budget de
l'administration pénitentiaire en 2024
par rapport à
2023 soit un budget de 3,9 milliards
d'euros la progression du budget d'AP
reprendra en
2025 à la faveur de la dernière vague de
mise en chantier des des établissements
pénitentiaires euh restant
du plan immobilier pénitentiaire vous
savez les 15000 places ou 18000 me me
demande t de dire parfois mais j'attends
qu'on fasse un certain nombre de
propositions sur cette sur cette
question plus 3 % au bénéfice de la PGJ
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
atteignant donc 950 millions d'euros
pour
2024 contre 922 millions en 203 et on
fait un plus 9 % pour le secrétariat
général du ministère passant ainsi de
642 millions en 2023 à 702 millions en
2024 2024 est donc une étape majeure
dans le rattrapage de ces années
d'abandon budgétaire politique et
humain auquel le président de la
République a décidé de mettre un coup
d'arrêt et répare pas un abandon de de
de 30 ans on a un claquement de doigt
mais nous sommes me semble-t-il en voie
d'amélioration pour ne pas dire en bonne
voie 2021 2022 2023 2024 l'année change
mais le cap reste toujours le même
restaurer la place de la justice à la
hauteur de la mission fondamentale qui
est la sienne à la hauteur de
l'engagement bien sûr de ceux qui la
servent et surtout à la hauteur des
attentes des fr
au nom de qui il ne faut jamais
l'oublier elle est rendue je veux euh
solennellement remercier ici votre
commission et le Sénat dans son ensemble
qui a accompagné par son vote chacune de
ses Hauses massiv de
moyens il est désormais essentiel que de
manière très concrète ces hausses
budgétaires puissent directement
améliorer le fonctionnement de la
justice comme nous commençons d'ailleurs
à le percevoir grâce ce moyen d'ors et
déjà déployé lors des précédentes lois
de finances et je veux prendre un seul
exemple les délais les délais de justice
j'ai fixé euh lors de la présentation du
plan d'action pour la justice un
objectif clair celui de drastiquement
réduire tous les délais de justice ça
passe évidemment d'abord par la
réduction des stocks d'affaires et je
soulligne que d'ors et déjà on a obtenu
grâce à ces moyens et à l'engagement de
nos magistrats de nos greffiers et des
contractuels une baisse des stocks
allant jusqu'à 30 % selon naturellement
les matières et les juridictions et ce
entre janvier 2021 et et la fin 2022 je
rappelle d'ailleurs d'un mot que nous
avons mis en place au 1er
novembre une politique de l'amiable qui
vise notamment à réduire les délais en
matière
civil mais je veux être clair il faut
aller plus loin que chacun prête toute
sa part dans cet effort
collectif je je je crois que les
Français ne pourrai pas comprendre que
l'État consacre autant d'argent à notre
justice et vous savez je crois à quel
point je me suis battu pour obtenir ces
budgets sans que ces moyens n'amélior
concrètement le service publicque de la
justice qui est rendu à nos compatriotes
les efforts des contribuables nous
obligent à des résultats ces résultats
ne pourront être atteints qu'avec la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs du
monde judiciaire ont pu compter sur moi
pour décrocher ses budgets sur le
Parlement pour les voter et moi je sais
qu'on peut compter sur eux pour que ces
moyens tant attendus et mérités
d'ailleurs au regard de l'engagement des
magistrats des greffiers de tous ceux
qui servent notre justice et rapidement
des effets
concrets pour les justiciaable c'est un
impératif et il en va de la crédibilité
de notre justice aux yeux de tous
mesdames messieurs s'agissant maintenant
des emplois la priorité de ce budget est
d'accélérer le rythme de recrutement
pour tenir le cap fixé par la loi de
programmation qui prévoit la création de
10000 emplois supplémentaire sur ce
quinquenin nous dépasserons ainsi en
2027 la barre des 100000 personnels au
sein du ministère et afin de de
conserver une certaine flexibilité c'est
10000 emplois seront répartis année
après année en fonction des besoins
métiers de l'avancement des projets bien
sûr et des capacités de recrutement et
de formation des écoles comme le prévoit
la loi d'orientation de programmation
nous créerons 1500 postes de magistrats
supplémentaires et 1800
postes grâce au Sénat je je dis grâce de
greffier supplémentaire sur le quinquena
et par ailleurs entre 2023 et 2025 euh
1100 attachés de justice seront recrutés
afin de
créer une équipe une véritable équipe
autour du
magistrat pour lui permettre de se
concentrer sur son cœur de métier dire
le droit trancher les litiges et bien
évidemment rendre la justice je voudrais
un un instant insister sur un point qui
n'a pas toujours été bien compris et
notamment au cours des débats
parlementaires et je bas ma
coupe parfois de B une
fois mais parfois de mauvaise concernant
ces créations nettes
d'emploi je dois dire que comme leur nom
le suggère ce sont des créations nettes
ça va s'en dire mais c'est bien de le
répéter autrement dit elles viennent en
plus du remplacement de tous les départs
en retraite et je vais prendre un
exemple sur les 1500 postes de
magistrats supplémentaires c'est en
réalité un recrutement de près de
2800 magistrats pour compenser
évidemment je l'ai dit les départs à la
retraite et les chiffres que je vous
annonce ne sont pas des trompeleœuil ils
représentent une augmentation concrète
précise vérifiable des effectifs dans
les juridictions par rapport à
aujourd'hui j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer la répartition géographique
par cours d'appel de ces renforts
judiciaires le 31 août dernier à Colmar
avec avec je prends quelques exemples 91
magistrats supplémentaires sur le
ressort de doué au moins 127 greffiers
supplémentaires sur le ressort de
versaill ou encore 72 attachés de
justice d'ici
2025 sur le ressort d'ex en Provence et
je rappelle que cette première
répartition géographique traduite en
réalité deux principes
cardinaux d'une part
l'objectivité la répartition nationale
entre cours d'appel tient compte de
plusieurs critères
objectifs du niveau des stocks de
l'évolution du nombre des affaires sur
les 10 dernières années de la
délinquence de données socio-économiques
et des prévisions de croissance
démographique et d'autre part la
confiance dans les acteurs de terrain
pour ce que l'on appelle on engage un
peu techno le le le dernier kilomètre
j'ai souhaité que la répartition au sein
de chaque cours d'appel revienne au chef
de cour d'appel afin qu'il puisse
répartir les efforts en réalité au plus
près des besoins des juridictions de
leur ressort qui j'en fais le le
[Musique]
l'aveu sont sont mieux connu évidemment
des chefs de cours que du garde des SS
voilà c'est d'ailleurs c'était
d'ailleurs une demande forte des chefs
de cours que de faire ce dialogue de
gestion rénové totalement nouveau
avec les différents TJ qu'ils ont sous
leur sous leur direction et donc nous
connaîtrons très prochainement cette
répartition moi j'ai annoncé les
chiffres cours d'appel par cours d'appel
à charge ensuite pour les chefs de cours
dans un dialogue de gestion avec les
chefs de juridiction d'attribuer tel ou
tel nombre de magistrats de greffi de
contractuel concernant 2024 une
autorisation de recrutement maximale de
210 ETP en plus des emplacement retraite
départ à la retraite a été accordé au
ministère et par comparaison avec les
créations netes d'emploi qui seront
faites par l'État au au global le
ministère de la Justice représentera
près du tiers de tous les agents publics
recrutés en
2024 pour
rappel en 2022 720 emplois avaient été
créés par le ministère de la Justice on
a triplé ce chiffre en 2023 et les
créations se maintiendront à ce niveau
exceptionnel en 2024 2110 ETP seront
répartis de la façon suivante alors 1307
pour la justice judiciaire avec
notamment 327 magistrats 340 greffiers
400 attachés de justice et parmi ces
personnels 33 seront spécifiquement
alloués au renforcement des capacités de
formation de
l'ENM dont 22 magistrats et vous savez
que cette promotion et et la prochaine
seront des promotions historiques
l'école est tellement pleine d'ailleurs
que on a dû trouver d'autres locaux pour
héberger tous les étudiants qui ont
passé le concours et qui souhaitent
évidemment accéder à la magistrature
jusqu'à 599 personnels pour
l'administration pénitentiare dont 512
surveillants ce chiffre
correspond comp une possibilité de
rattrapage de 149
pai précédant procédante à une d'une
sous-exécution antérieure et l'École
Nationale de l'Administration
pénitencière quant à elle sera renforcé
de trois emplois supplémentaires 92 ETP
pour la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse et le reste soit 112
personnels bénéficiera à la coordination
de la politique publique de la justice
et plus particulièrement au secrétariat
général mesdames Messieurs les
sénateursag sissant maintenant des
rémunérations nous renforçons
l'attractivité des métiers de justice
afin de pouvoir
assurer ce niveau inédit de recrutement
les rémunérations participent évidemment
de cette
attractivité alors à titre comparatif je
rappelle qu'à mon arrivée en 2020
l'enveloppe catégorielle servante à
revaloriser les professionnels du
ministère était de 17 millions d'euros
avant de passer à 50 millions d'euros
par an en en 2021 et 2022 puis 110
millions en 2023 dont
millions de mesures nouvelles pour
2024 j'ai le plaisir d'annoncer que
cette enveloppe catégorielle augmentera
à nouveau
significativement pour atteindre un
montant de plus de 170 millions dont 64
millions de mesures nouvelles ceci
représente une multiplication par 10
depuis mon arrivée
et cette progression inédite nous engage
par ailleurs les crédits
interministériels permettront de
financer les mesures catégorielles
issues de la conférence salariale du
mois de juin 2023 à hauteur de 33
million d'euros pour le ministère ces
mesures permettront principalement
l'injection de 5 points d'indice
supplémentaires pour l'ensemble des
agents du ministère dès le 1er janvier
2024 àin de prendre en considération
l'inflation s'agissant des grandes
mesures de revalorisation qui seront
financé cette enveloppe catégorielle de
170 millions pour 2024 se répartira de
la façon suivante s'agissant des
magistrat comme annoncé l'année dernière
une revalorisation inédite a été mise en
place depuis octobre 2023 atteignant
1000 € brut par
mois par magistrat en moyenne et cette
mesure représente un effort budgétaire
de
88,5 million d'euros en 24 elle est
nécessaire pour maintenir
l'attractivité de ce métier et et pour
aligner la rémunération de nos
magistrats de l'ordre judiciaire avec la
rémunération de leurs collègues de
l'ordre
administrative les magistrats n'avaient
pas été réévalués de depuis je crois
1996 cette mesure elle est aussi
légitime pour témoigner évidemment de
notre reconnaissance à leur égard et
leur régime indemnitaire je je je li à
part quelques revalorisation spécifique
assez modeste n'avait pas vu de
modification depuis des temps très
anciens concernant les surveillants
pénitentiaires et les
officiers j'ai annoncé en février
dernier qu'à comptter du 1er janvier de
l'année prochaine les surveillants
pénitentiaires passeront en catégorie
B tandis que les officiers passeront en
catégorie A avec des revalorisations
indemnitaires et indiciaire en parallèle
alors que les contours de cette réforme
seront bientôt
tracés je peux déjà dire qu'en terme
budgétaire 47 millions seront
sanctuarisés pour la financer il s'agit
je le rappelle devant vous d'une réforme
inédite destinée évidemment à rendre
hommage au personnel pénitentiaire quiil
mérite mais
également destiné à recruter il s'agit
de que l'on reconnaisse l'importance des
métiers pénitentiaires que l'on prenne
en compte la la la
complexité la difficulté parfois la
dangerosité de leur mission je porte la
même attention aux autres fonctionnaires
de ce ministère qui ne seront pas
oubliés avec en particulier une
revalorisation indiciaire et
indemnitaire de la filière
GREF à hauteur de 15 millions d'euros
première étape je dis bien première
étape d'une réforme approfondie de ce
corps la poursuite des mesures
transverses porté par le Secrétariat
général à hauteur de
15,5 millions d'euros des mesures en
faveur des corps spécifiques de la PJJ
pour 3
millions madame la rapporteur haribet
une revalorisation du corps de direction
de laadap et des personnels du service
national du renseignement pénitentiaire
à hauteur de 1 million et par ailleurs
en complément de cette enveloppe de 170
millions une mesure de revalorisation
des magistrats ainsi qu'une mesure
catégorielle complémentaire en faveur
des greffiers sera octroyé avec une
enveloppe pouvant atteindre 22,5
millions d'euros en
2024 pour les grefs
cette mesure va s'accompagner d'une
réforme statutaire
d'envergure conformément à l'accord
majoritaire que que j'ai signé avec
trois des quatre organisations
syndicales le mois dernier articulé
autour de de trois axes premier lieu
restructuration du corps de greffier de
catégorie B qui permettra une
accélération de leur carrière et un
accès plus plus ouvert à l'échelon
somital de greffier
principal
ensuite la création d'un corps de
greffier de catégorie A d'une volumétrie
de
3200 agents ce qui permettra la
reconnaissance de l'expertise des
greffiers sur leur mission
juridictionnelle notamment greffiers
principaux et fonctionnels et
enfin un plan pluriannuel de
requalification des agents de catégorie
C ce que ce que l'on appelle les
faisants fonction qui permettra là
encore la reconnaissance des compétences
de métier dont nous savons toutes et
tous qu'ils sont absolument
indispensables à la justice de notre
pays et sans attendre la mise en œuvre
de la nouvelle grille indiciaire
annoncée en septembre dernier je
rappelle qu'alors qu'un greffier en
milieu de carrière sur des missions
classique percevez au 31 décembre 2021
2312 € brut mensuel alors il s'agit là
du traitement de base plus des primes il
perçoit aujourd'hui de 1606 € brut ce
qui
représente une augmentation de 294 €
brut par mois soit une une progression
mensuelle de sa rémunération de l'ordre
de 13 % alors en matière de
revalorisation mon CAP est tout à fait
clair c'est celui de l'attractivité de
tous les métier de justice et la
fidélisation bien sûr des femmes et des
hommes qui uvrent à à son service et
donc au service de nos concitoyens c'est
un enjeu de de de reconnaissance de leur
engagement monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis Vogel s'agissant de la
programmation immobilière
pénitentiaire ces crédits vont permettre
de poursuivre le plan de construction
voulu par le Président de la République
pour mémoire le plan portera à plus de
75000 le nombre total de places de
prison disponibles à horizon 2000 27 en
érigeant
51 51 nouveaux établissements
pénitentiaire je j'y suis pleinement
engagé et et fin 2024 nous aurons
réalisé la moitié du chemin avec 23
nouveaux établissements
opérationnels sur les 51 prévus plus
précisément concernant
2023 ce sont 11 établissements qui qui
auront été mis en service comme je m'y
étais engagé devant vous l'année
dernière et en 2024 le programme de
construction se poursuivra avec la même
intensité et concernera se chantiers
quatre nouveaux établissements seront
livrés à Toulon noisilgrand Colmar nî
trois sites pénitentiaires finaliseront
leur première phase de travaux Bordeaux
Gradignan Baster et
bemmao
en 2024 ce sont 308 millions d'euros qui
seront budgetés pour la réalisation du
programme de construction pénitencière à
ce jour ce sont près de 2 milliards
d'euros qui ont été investis dans ce
plan de construction par rapport à un
coût estimatif total de 5 milliards
d'euros enfin les réhabilitations
d'établissement
existant évidemment vous en toucher un
mot les opérations courantes de de de
maintenance représenteront 130 millions
d'euros en
2024 nous maintenons ce ce ce très haut
niveau d'investissement annuel qui
représente je je le rappelle le double
de celui qui était investi entre 2012 et
2017 concernant freine et poissie 2
millions d'euros seront en particulier
consacrés aux études de leur
réhabilitation
devenusolument indispensable
madame la rapporteur pour avis caniller
on peut pas évoquer l'immobilier
pénitentiaire sans l'immobilier
judiciaire pour lequel je souhaite
évidemment poursuivre la modernisation
et l'agrandissement afin notamment de
permettre l'accueil des renforts humains
que j'ai détaillé au début de mon propos
au total c'est 362 millions qui seront
consacrés en 2024 à l'immobilier
judiciaire propriétaire par rapport à
269 9 million d'euros en 2023 c'est une
ha vous avez déjà fait le calcul de près
de 35 %. ces crédits permettront de
poursuivre notamment les 20 principaux
chantiers dont trois nouveaux paliis de
justice 15 restructurations extension de
palais de justice existant de
réhabilitations de bâtimentiè pour
construire des annexe au Palais de
Justice enfin pour finir je souhaite
mettre en lumière quelques enveloppes
qui me ent à cœur car elles ont pour
vocation de de de moderniser et
d'améliorer concrètement le
fonctionnement du service public de la
justice ainsi que le bien-être de ces
agents tout d'abord madame la rapporteur
pour avis verir les crédit
d'investissement
informatique dont les techniques
d'enquête numérique judiciaire sonont
portter à 209 millions d'euros soit une
hausse de 7,2 % en une année ces crédits
qui vont permettre en particulier de
poursuivre le second plan de
transformation numérique du ministère
qui est un plan de numérisation de la
justice en France et ce plan va
s'articuler autour de trois projets
principaux un plan de soutien au profit
des agents du ministère sur le terrain
et en particulier au cœur au sein des
juridictions ça passe par le recrutement
de 100 techniciens informatique de
proximité en 2023 dont 80 ont d'ors et
déjà été recrutés puis 100 autres
techniciens supplémentaires seront
recrutés en 2024 pour ceux qui comme
vous
euh se rendre dans les dans les
juridictions le plantage pardon je
m'exprime de façon familière de la bécan
un vendredi soir c'est
insupportable ça génère de de de la
frustration de la difficulté alors on on
remontait d'abord euh info à la DSJ
quand c'était pas au secrétariat général
voire au deux le temps que les deux se
connectent bon voilà puis on n pas des
techniciens informatiques donc on a
envoyé les techniciens informatiques
pour aider au plus près au plus près du
terrain modernisation des logiciels
métiers alors je vais vous donner un un
exemple mais d'abord je je veux vous
dire quel est notre objectif 100 % de
numérisation d'ici la fin du quinquen 0
papier ça avance concrètement je vais
vous donner un seul exemple à mon
arrivée la PPN la fameuse PPN procédure
pénale numérique était en état
embrionnaire il y avait environ 500
procédures transmises de manière
dématérialisée des enquêteur vers le
tribunaux par
mois depuis juin
dernier avec l'aide du ministère de
l'Intérieur le chiffre a été multiplié
par 300 et on en est à 140 43000
procédures transmis
mensuellement et la direction du
programme PPN intérieur justice a été
créé justement en juin et va permettre
d'accélérer de façon
décisive
cette
progression l'enveloppe de crédit
consacré aux dépenses frais de justice
rapporté à
674 millions d'euros en
2024 pour renforcer les moyens d'enquête
et d'expertise de la justice soit une
hausse de 14 millions supplémentaires
par rapport à 2023 et par rapport à 2000
27 où le budget consacré était de
496 millions ça représente un effort de
36 %
d'augmentation bien sûr euh et et bien
sûr ce nouvel
effort doit nous amener euh vers une
facilitation du du du du
déstockage les crédits de l'accès au
droit à la justice vont s'élever à 734
millions d'EUR en 2024 soit une une
hausse de 3 % par rapport à 2023 qui
s'établissait à 714 millions d'euros
plus spécifiquement dans cette enveloppe
les crédits dédiés à l'aide
juridictionnelle continueront à croître
en 2024 pour atteindre 657 millions soit
16 million de plus en une année et
parallèlement l'aide aux victimes est
porté à 47 millions en 2024 soit une
hausse de 2 million d'euros par rapport
à 2023 monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci Monsieur le Ministre
alors plusieurs demandes d'intervention
d'abord mesame caniller Dominique veren
sur volet justice judiciaire et ACC au
droit puis ensuite madame Laurence
aribet sur le volet protection judiciire
la jeunesse puis Monsieur Louis Vogel
sur le volet administration
pénitentiaire ensuite madame delâre puis
Monsieur Philippe bonnecarer et Monsieur
alanmarc si d'autres veulent s'inscrire
c'est possible bien madame
caniller merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des saau alors que
l'encre de des projets de loi
d'orientation et de programmation de la
justice est à peine sèche nous voilà de
nouveau euh a euh euh discuter échanger
sur la trajectoire et les crédits
budgétaires de votre ministère alors
évidemment comme nous l'avons dit
dernièrement nous nous félicitons une
fois de plus de cette augmentation des
crédits de la budget du budget de la
justice et euh notamment de sa
transcription en moyen supplémentairire
et avant tout en moyen humain nous
félicitons du recrutement des 1500
magistrats donc 2800 euh pour euh euh
prendre en compte les départs en
retraite et qui viendront combler nous
espérons les 400 postes vacants
aujourd'hui encore dans nos juridictions
et renforcer euh les équipes
juridictionnelles et évidemment nous
félicitons des des 1800 greffiers
néanmoins si cela pose la question de
comment euh recruter ça pose aussi la
question de pourquoi monsieurgard Desso
pourquoi recruter et donc principalement
la question aussi de la charge du
travail des magistrats euh le
référentiel euh de travaillé par la DSJ
en relation avec les les les
représentants des syndicats et
manifestement prêt pour la première
juridiction première instance pardon en
cours d'expérimentation est-ce que peut
savoir quand est-ce qu'il sera
dévoilé ça pose aussi la question de la
restructuration sera ma deuxième
question de l'équipe autour du magistrat
qui est un axe fort parce qu'il suffit
pas de donner des moyens supplémentaires
je pense nous pensons et ce que nous
avons défendu dans le projet de loi qui
était essentiel au côté de réorganiser
le travail les magistrats et ça pose la
question de la place des greffiers qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu perdus dans
cette équipe autour du magistrat alors
certes
ils se réjouissent des revalorisations
du passage en catégorie A d'un certain
nombre d'entre eux mais cela crée chez
eux un certain nombre d'incertitude
alors on aimerait avoir un peu plus de
clarté sur votre vision de cette équipe
autour du
magistrat trème question et je vais être
assez rapide c'est sur l'histoire les
frais vous nous avez dit effectivement
une augmentation de 14 millions d'euros
augmentation tendantielle de 37 % depuis
2020 on voit que c'est ça monte en
flèche pensez-vous et que vous arriverez
à juguler ces frais de justice et si oui
comment comptez-vous vous y prendre et
ma dernière question 2024 c'est une
année Jo qui dit J dit évidemment que il
y aura une demande forte qui pesera sur
la chaîne pénal les juridictions seront
très sollicitées pensez-vous qu'elles
sont prêtes
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour cette
présentation alors bah moi je vais tout
de suite rentrer dans le vif du sujet
dont vous savez qui
m'intéresse l'informatique alors merci
beaucoup pour les techniciens dans les
tribunaux ça je crois que ça va aider
énormément les greffiers et les
magistrats tellement effectivement ça
plante régulièrement et donc du coup de
noms qui reviennent depuis 4 ans dans
nos conversations Portalis
Cassiopé quand enfin arrêterons-nous
d'en parler sauf pour dire que super ça
fonctionne vous parlez de zéro papier en
2027 alors zéro papier c'est pas
seulement la procédure pénale numérique
c'est plus ambitieux est-ce qu'il faut
pas déjà se concentrer entrer sur bah
déjà la procédure pénale numérique parce
que effectivement ça a beaucoup augmenté
mais très majoritairement c'est les
petits X qui remontent donc on n est pas
encore à avoir des dossiers qui seront
ensuite traités pour de vrai par par les
magistrats euh donc est-ce qu'il faut
pas plutôt se se concentrer vraiment sur
les sujets sur lesquels on a du mal à
aboutir aujourd'hui euh donc ça bon
voilà il fallait que je commence par ça
ensuite bah du coup c'est moi qui vais
attaquer sur l'immobilier puisque à
chaque audition à peu près au niveau de
l'immobilier les les utilisateurs en
fait nous font la remarque que n'avait
pas été anticipé et ça malheureusement
on peut pas vous le reprocher parce que
mais anticiper le fait queil allait y
avoir de nombreux recrutements donc
merci pour les nombreux recrutements
mais comment est-ce qu'on va gérer
aujourd'hui des bâtiments qui sortent
tout neufs mais déjà trop petits euh
donc par ailleurs de toute façon ils
nous ont quand même fait remarquer
qu'ils étaient assez en tout cas trop
peu associés à la programmation des
bâtiments dans lesquels ils allaient
devoir travailler et ce qui peut être
regrettable donc est-ce que vous
entendez peut-être modifier un peu la
façon dont la programmation des des
futurs bâtiments se font et puis euh je
ne vous ai pas entendu parler d'une
politique à ce sujet d'économie
d'énergie parce que si on veut trouver
de l'argent bah la meilleure façon c'est
de pas le dépenser et et on a quand même
un certain nombre de tribunaux qui sont
des vrais passoirs thermiques donc
est-ce que ça fait partie d'un plan
prévisionnel et enfin dernière question
qui va concerner les tribunaux de
commerce et futurs tribunaux des
affaires économiques euh vous savez nous
avons accompagné cette démarche de de
faire cette expérimentation sur sur les
tribunaux des affaires économiques quand
euh alors on est un peu en dehors du
budget mais là encore c'est vraiment une
question quand seront connus les futurs
sites qui pourront faire cette
expérimentation par contre là je reviens
vraiment sur le budget puisque nous
avons créé des recettes afférentes à ces
tribunaux des affaires économiques
est-ce qu'il y a une possibilité pour
que les recette soit fléché à minima sur
le budget de la justice voire sur le
budget des tribunaux de commerce futur
tribunaux des affaires économiques et
justement puisque ça permettrait
probablement de à ces magistrat d'avoir
un petit budget pour les aider ne
serait-ce que pour acheter leurs robes
ou acheter un peu de papier et enfin et
je reboucle du coup sur ma première
question qui est le numérique à quand
des des adresses mail
dédié merci Madame Verrien madame
Laurence sibet sur la
PG merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre merci de de cette
présentation alors pour la PJJ euh vous
l'avez dit relative stabilité de du du
budget de la PGJ puisqu'on est à peu
près à 3 % d'augmentation mais il faut
souligner et rappeler qu'on avait 10 %
l'année l'année précédente et donc on
est dans une dans une année plus de de
confirmation que d'expansion de la euh
de de ce budget euh et puis il faut
souligner aussi qu'il y a eu des efforts
particuliers qui sont engagés depuis
plus plusieurs années sur en particulier
la rémunération dans ce dans ce secteur
mais c'est un un un bilan en demi-teinte
finalement et j'ai trois questions à
vous poser la première concerne les
CF je sais que vous êtes très très
attaché à à cette manière de traiter la
question des mineurs avec notamment le
programme d'ouverture de de 20 CF et
d'ici
2027 euh et j'aimerais vous interroger
sur l'appréciation du récent rapport de
la Cour des comptes euh qui euh qui met
en qui qui interroge en tout cas sur le
taux d'occupation qui est seulement 68 %
et qui interroge sur la la
l'augmentation du nombre de
constructions alors que le taux
d'occupation n'est pas très satisfaisant
euh et en plus ce que soulligne aussi un
certain nombre de professionnels
c'est le le risque de d'effet d'éviction
avec ces CF c'est-à-dire le fait que on
va recourir au CF et que d'autres
d'autres places dans d'autres types de
de centres peuvent être délaissé et donc
on peut avoir une offre de de de
placement des des autres pistes moindre
que ce qu'on ce dont on aurait besoin
voilà donc une première question autour
des SEF la deuxième question est sur
l'impact de l'entrée en en vigueur du
code de la justice des mineurs euh on le
sait la l'année enfin la mise en œuvre
du code se traduit par une diminution de
la durée des placements donc on peut
s'en réjouir sur le fond mais cela pose
un problème au personnel de la de la PJJ
puisque en fait l'idée de d'avoir un
parcours et historiquement ce parcours
était sur un minimum de de 6 mois or
aujourd'hui on est à une moyenne de
durée de placement de 4 mois et demi et
donc ça remet un petit peu en cause
enfin en cause ça remet ça bouleverse un
petit peu en tout cas les pratiques
dans de métier et donc la question que
j'aimerais vous poser c'est comment
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire pour
concilier le tempo de l'éducatif et
celui judiciaire et notamment comment
préserver les séjours de rupture de
plusieurs mois qui ont fait la preuve de
leur de leur efficacité mais qui
deviennent euh plus rares avec la
réforme et la dernière interrogation que
je voudrais euh sur laquelle j'aimerais
poser une question c'est en fait le
déploiement de parcours qui visiblement
pose pose problème et j'aimerais savoir
quel est le calendrier d'aboutissement
de parcours le la Cour des comptes parle
de de 2032
euh donc comment quelle réaction vous
avez à cette à cette appréciation de euh
de de la Cour des comptes sachant quand
même que parcours a déjà coûté 10
million pour la pour la mise en forme de
la première partie et de la du premier
volet de la première partie euh et que
visiblement le choix qui a été fait qui
peut se comprendre de faire construire
par les acteurs le le le système fait
que en fait c'est très long et notamment
le le le le secteur associatif habilité
n'est n'est toujours pas dans la boucle
alors qu'il représente la grande
majorité de du déplacement voilà les
trois questions que je voudrais vous
poser
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Ministre merci d'être avec nous et je
souhaiterais vous poser deux questions
la première et je pense que il faut
saluer votre action puisque le budget de
la justice augmente globalement ça
concerne aussi la pénitentiaire et il
était grand temps de de le faire
donc il y a rien à dire nous on a
l'habitude souvent de critiquer ce qui
va pas mais je pense qu'il faut
souligner les progrès quand ils se font
euh mais alors ce qu'on constate c'est
que au sein de ce budget le budget de
l'insertion et de l'probation est en
réduction euh or tout le monde considère
aujourd'hui que l'insertion et
l'approbation sont quand même les
meilleurs moyens de de lutter contre la
récidive donc ma question est la
suivante ma première question est la
suivante comptez-vous revaloriser ce
secteur et comment comptez-vous vous y
prendre seconde question concerne la
surpopulation
carcérale alors on dit couramment que la
surpopulation carcérale est liée à
l'augmentation des peines pendant tout
un temps on a pensé que les alternatives
à la prison permettraient de réduire le
nombre de détenus les nombr des détenus
passant de la prison à autre chose en
réalité le récent rapport de la Cour des
comptes dont il a été question montre
que les deux courbes croissent
parallèlement c'està-dire qu'il y a une
augmentation du nombre de détenus et des
personnes de plus en plus nombreuses qui
suivent des qui subissent des peines
alternatives alors ma question la
suivante quelle politique pénale
entendez-vous mener face à cette donnée
qui est quand même difficile à traité
comment comptez-vous et plus
généralement comment aujourd'hui
comptez-vous agir pour réduire
efficacement le nombre de
détenus voilà voilà une question directe
euh merci madame de
lâre puis monsieur boncarrère oui merci
président monsieur le ministre
j'interviens en tant que rapporteur pour
avis de la mission Direction de l'action
du gouvernement incluant les crédits du
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté et de la direction
du numérique de l'État
d'ome notamment j'ai eu l'occasion
d'étudier les récents rapports du CGLPL
ainsi que les grands projets numériques
de votre ministère j'aimerais soulever
donc quelques questions à ce sujet la
première une préoccupation récurrente
des rapports du CGLPL concerne la
surpopulation carcérale le gouvernement
répond à cela par un plan de
construction de 15000 places de prison
d'ici à 2027 revue à la hausse par la
loi d'orientation et programmation
2023-2027 la CGLPL dans un avis de
juillet dernier qualifie ce programme
immobilier d'irréaliste je m'interroge
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre sur le
calendrier déploiement du chantier et le
rythme de livraison pour 2024 par
ailleurs considérez-vous que ces projets
immobiliers suffisent en eux même à
réseau la question de la surpopulation
carcérale je renvoie la question de mon
collègue exemple Gradignan où l'on me
dit que la nouvelle construction de 6002
602 places euh sera à son
déjà connaîtra son ouverture déjà une
surpopulation nous avons aujourd'hui un
taux d'occupation de 825 détenus en ce
qui concerne le CGLPL 2è question
j'ajouterai que dans son rapport
d'activité l'autorité observe que le
suivi des recommendation par les
ministres demeurent un exercice formel
et fastidieux mentionnant un taux de
réalisation des recommandations
relativement faible je m'interroge donc
sur l'existence d'un suivi effectif des
rapports et recommandations de cette
autorité
indépendante dans un second temps
j'aimerais aborder une autre priorité du
budget de la justice pour 2024 qui est
la transformation numérique parmi les 52
grands projets numériques de l'État qui
font l'objet d'un suivi par la direction
du numérique de l'État SEP sont portés
par votre ministère je note cependant
les écarts budgétaires et calendaires de
ces projets qui s'accroissent en 2024
avec des augmentations moyenne de 15 %
des coûts et de 29 % de la durée par
rapport aux estimations initiales alors
que c'est écarts étit respectivement de
5 et 7 % lors de l'exercice précédent
pourriez-vous expliquer ces dérives
comment ces projets ainsi que le deuxème
plan de transformation numérique dans
son ensemble sont-ils suivis et pilotés
par les services de nototre ministère et
quelle a été la portée des
recommandations éventuellement formulé
par la dinyome enfin 4è point là c'est
un point girondin sur la modernisation
du matériel les surveillants de
Gradignan par exemple réglam du matériel
moderne qu'il n'obtiennent pas me dit-on
parce que cela coûte trop cher exemple
des drones d'interception et de
surveillance ceux d'en face ont des
drones pour livrer drogues et objets
divers des pistolets à impulsion
électriquees lors des fouill de
de de cellules qui peuvent s'avérer
nécessaires ainsi que des caméras piéton
lors d'intervention ou dans les SAS les
structures d'aménagement à la sortie
quand les surveillants hommes se
retrouvent seul avec des dé tenu femmes
je vous remercie merci Monsieur boncer
oui monsieur le ministre la remise à
niveau de la justice française est
indiscutablement apporté à votre à votre
crédit et nous sommes maintenant sur un
sujet de mise en œuvre et je partage le
tropisme de Madame Verrien sur la
question Informatique vous avez évoqué
209 millions d'euros d'investissement au
budget 2024 deux questions de ma part
par la première question concerne les
montants qui sont effectivement investis
je serais curieux de connaître le taux
d'exécution sur cet enemmenée par sur
cet ennée de vos investissements
informatiques en fonction des chiffres
que n avez donné le volume devait être
tourné autour de 190 millions d'euros je
serais curiux de savoir si ces crédits
ont été engagés à 100 % ou pas deuxè
question la gestion de nos collectivités
locales nous a appris monsieur le
ministre
que les bons projet les bonnes
réalisations obéissez à un secret très
simple un bon projet c'est une bonne
maîtrise d'ouvrage une bonne maîtrise
d'œuvre et un bon dialogue entre la
maîtrise d'ouvrage et la maîtrise
d'œuvre je seraai là également curieux
de savoir comment ceci est organisé dans
votre
ministère maîtrise d'ouvrage dans vos
services maîtrise d'ouvrage aussi de des
magistrats ou sur le le terrain qui est
votre maîtrise d'œuvre est-ce que elle
est totalement externalisée et comment
vous organisez le dialogue entre les
deux pour que tout ceci fonctionne il
m'a sembla les lire et qu'il y avait eu
un rapport durant le courant de l'année
de l'Inspection générale des finances et
de l'inspection des services judiciaires
qui se posait quand même quelques
questions sur ce dialogue si vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur bon carère
monsieur
larc merci président à mon tour je je
salue l'augmentation du budget monsieur
le ministre j'avais une question j'ai
été à l'École nationale d'administration
pénitentiire à à agin il c'était il y a
2 ans et vous avez évoqué le fait qu'il
y avait eu beaucoup moins de candidats
que ceux qui avait une sous-exécution du
recrutement lors des années précédentes
d'ailleurs des surveillants
pénitentiaires et qui plus est euh un
niveau qui est encore très bas or on
sait que aujourd'hui il y a une cellule
de renseignement dans les prisons et que
notamment pour rédiger des rapports il
faut être assez synthétique et avoir une
culture minimale dans un certain domaine
dans certains domaines qui permettent
ensuite d'apprécier la réalité des
rapports qui sont transmis je voudrais
savoir comment vous allez vous y prendre
pour améliorer l'attractivité de ces
métiers et puis j'avais une autre
question sur les conciliateurs de
justice il me semble qu'il n'y a il me
semble très modestement qu'il n'y a pas
assez peut-être de publicité faite nous
avons quand même un nombre de de
bénévoles assez considérable de jeunes
retraités qui peut-être iraiit euh
pourrai faire conciliateur de justice
dans la mesure où ils aurit une culture
juridique minimale comment entendez-vous
faire cette publicité là de façon à ce
que plus de personnes s'investissent
dans cette dans ces
fonctionsl merci Monsieur Marc madame
Mariepierre
lagagonri merci monsieur le président
monsieur le
ministre je je voulais vous vous
interroger sur un point donc je pensais
que Dominique
Verrien l'aborderait dont je pensais non
oui que je pensais enfin bref je pensais
qu'elle l'aborderait
euh vous avez publié le 24 novembre avec
un sens aigu du
calendrier un décret portant création
des pôles spécialisés dans la lutte
contre les violences intrafamiliales qui
seront donc généralisés au 1er janvier
de l'année prochaine à la veille de la
Journée Internationale euh pour
l'élimination des violences faites aux
femmes est-ce que vous pourriez euh nous
détailler comment tout cela va se passer
d'un point de vue budgétaire ressources
en personnel sachant que ce qu'on voit
c'est que le nombre
de de plainte augmente de manière
considérable certains je pense qu'ils
ont raison s'en réjouissent en montrant
que la parole s libéré et que donc
maintenant les les
femmes vont davantage même si elles ne
le font pas toutes vers la police ou la
gendarmerie mais qu'il y a en face un
problème de personnel qu'il s'agisse de
euh fonctionnaires de de police ou ou de
magistrat magistrats qui eux-mêm
sembl-il on g regardent des études qui
ont pu être faites euh ont du mal à
rester longtemps dans ces fonctions qui
qui qui suscitent une charge mentale
assez lourde euh et donc assez difficile
donc si vous pouviez nous dire un petit
peu maintenant que les les semaines et
les mois ont passé comment tout cela va
se dérouler à partir du 1er janvier 2024
puisque il y a déjà des sortes de
préfiguration dans un certain nombre de
J judiction voilà merci madame de La
gterie dernier intervenant monsieur
husin
Bourgi merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci aussi ah d'accord très
bien monsieur bourg vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre je vais
cette année encore me réjouir de
l'augmentation du budget et vous
interroger sur deux points le premier
qui vient d'être souligné par ma
collègue Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie
pour vous indiquer que les pôles
spécialisés certaines juridictions les
ont mis en place et ont été proactives
avant même que la circulaire que le
décret ne paraisse en revanche d'autres
juridictions me disent leur inquiétude
quant à la mise en œuvre optimale de
cespôules puisqueeffectivement les
magistrats chargé de ces violences
intrafamiliales doivent concomitamment
conserver les attributions antérieures
qui étaient les leurs et donc certains
magistrats me disent pour me charier me
provoquer en me disant il y a pas de
problème on va prioriser les violences
intrafamiliales mais ça se fera
nécessairement au détriment du reste euh
donc c'est un sujet sur lequel je je
voulais attirer votre attention parce
qu'effectivement ils me disent attention
à ne pas retourner l'opinion publique
qui aujourd'hui adhère à la grande cause
euh qui est la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes mais si
demain il se rendent compte que cette
priorité donnée aux violences
intrafamiliale se fait au détriment
d'autres types de contentieux en
l'occurrence desès l'UR ça pourrait
peut-être poser problème le second point
sur lequel je souhaitais attirer votre
attention qui est un problème que je
pensais être uniquement dans dans le
tribunal judiciaire de Montpellier
finalement je constate qu'il se qu'il se
réitère dans d'autres juridictions
aujourd'hui dans les services du jaff du
tribunal judiciaire de Montpellier il y
a 350 décisions de justice qui attendent
d'être mise en forme et d'être notifié
au partis et il y a 300 audiences qui
sont déjà déjà prévu mais qui n'ont pas
encore été notifiés aux avocats et aux
partis or vous le savez lorsqu'il s'agit
d'un contentieux familial plus la
période précédent la notification de la
décision est longue plus la situation
sans venime surtout lorsqu'il y a des
enfants lorsqu'il y a une situation qui
n'est pas définitivement figée et tout
le monde attire mon attention et
m'alerte sur le manque de moyens en
matière de greffi parce que lorsque les
décisions sont rendues il faut que les
greffiers les mettent en forme et les
notifi ce qui veut dire que dans mon
département il y a 350 familles qui sont
dans l'attente d'une décision qui a déjà
été prise mais qui n'a toujours pas été
notifiée et il y a 300 dates de
convocation pour des audiences qui sont
déjà arrêtées mais qui n'ont pas été
notifié au parti or plus la convocation
arrive tard plus est grand le risque que
l'avocat demande un report d'audience
donc comment nous pouvons faire pour
résoudre ce problème qui semble être
structurel de manque de greffier en
particulier dans le services du JAF
merci merci Monsieur et je crois cette
fois-ci madame merci dernière
intervention et après la parole est au
ministre monsieur
le en 2016 a été mis en place ce qu'on
appelle la tmfpo c'est-à-dire la
tentative de médiation familiale
préalable obligatoire c'était à titre
expérimental est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire 7 ans après s'il y a une évaluation
de faê sur l'efficacité de ce dispositif
et si c'est amené à être
pérénisé merci et bien monsieur le
ministre vous avez la
parole merci merci monsieur le Président
je vais essayer de répondre au mieux aux
très nombreuses questions que vous
m'avez
posé he pardon le micro voilà don don je
je je disais donc que j'allais essayer
là vous m'entendez ouais non de répondre
aux nombreuses questions qui m'ont été
posées et qui démontrent d'ailleurs tout
l'intérêt que vous
portez à la justice
alors on commence dans l'ordre s faeror
de ma part
par Madame madame caner n'est-ce
pas
alors vous me demandez au fond comment
comment piloter la mé en charge du plan
de
recrutement des 10000 les fameux 10000
bon alors euh je l'ai déjà dit 10000
recrutements nets son sont prévus
inscrit dans la loi de de d'orientation
de programmation
euh sanctuarison déjà 1500 magistrats et
et 1800 greffiers
bon ça représente une hausse très
importante 11 % des effectifs actuels je
rappelle qu'il y a 92000
agents et la
répartition plus plus fine de ces de ces
effectif se fera année par année je dit
également tout à l'heure en fonction des
besoins métiers et notamment de
l'avancement des projets en matière
pénitentiaire et naturellement des
capacités de recrutement formation des
écoles bon alors l'école nationale du
GREF je viens d'aller la accueillir la
prestation de serment de
la toute dernière promotion il y a
quelques jours c'est désormais quatre
promotions par an au lieu de deux donc
ça tourne à plein régime le nm a vu son
budget augmenter d'un ti3 ce qui lui
permet de recruter évidemment de
nouveaux enseignants d'élargir les
salles de cours de de décupler la
capacité de formation des auditeurs de
justice et nous avons là je l'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure rapidement mais je peux
m'y arrêter un instant véritable
difficulté pour héberger les auditeurs
de justice en tous les cas l'actuelle
promotion est la promotion historique
mais elle ne restera pas historique
longtemps parce
que la la la la promotion d'après est
encore plus importante on va frôer les
500 auditeurs de
justice ça nécessite évidemment ces
emplois
nouveau une adaptation du du parc
immobilier l'immobilier Jud
c'est précisément 699 bâtiments en
activité et pour accueillir les renforts
judiciaires il va s'agir évidemment de
pousser les murs mais aussi de
poursuivre un effort de modernisation
des palais de justice de construction et
la programmation immobilière quenal est
en cours de révision bien sûr à la
hausse avec la poursuite pour
2024 de TR nouveaux palais de
justice pour tre très précis Lille
Saint-Benoît à la Réunion Saint-Laurent
du Maroni deux
réhabilitations pour construire des
annexes au palais de justice à nior à
Valencienne et 15
restructurations de palais de justice
qui existe il s'agit de d'Arras Bayon
bourge Bourgouin bourgouinjalieu bien
sûr chumon Carcasson evri Fort de France
Macon Nancy Nant nanter Paris Cité
versaill et Vienne bon vous m'avez
interrogé
ensuite sur les frais de justice alors
sur les frais de
justice on apporta de deux actions
principales j'ai le 9 mai dernier j'ai
j'ai signé une dépêche relative aux
dépenses invitant les chefs de cours et
les chefs de juridiction a activé
ensemble les leviers qui sont à leur
mains pour maîtriser les coûts et j'ai
mis en place un plan de maîtrise selon
six axes en cours de mise en
œuvre revoir
l'organisation organisation des
juridictions automatiser les dépenses de
traduction mutualiser les frais de
gardienage mettre en place une
tarification sur le recours au
laboratoir aux investigation numérique
expérimenter un processus de destruction
des armes avec le ministère à
l'intérieur tout ça évidemment c'est un
cou voilà les quelques pistes que nous
mettons en place je suis tout à fait
ravi de vous recevoir à la
Chancellerie madame si vous souhaitez
que je vous donne des détails plus
précis sur la façon dont on envisage les
dépenses de justice au travers de ces
frais et naturellement une certaine
maîtrise vous avez une question commune
avec madame la sénatrice Verrien sur les
Jos
je je
vais vous répondre et commencer ma
réponse à Madame Verrien alors les j les
JO c'est
évidemment quelque chose que nous
attendons toutes et tous avec beaucoup
de d'enthousiasme
mais ça génère un certain nombre de
choix il faut renforcer les juridictions
qui sont j'allais dire les juridictions
sites
olympiques donc vous me demandez si on
sera prêt je pense que nous serons prêts
parce que nous avons anticipé de longues
dates euh les gios à Paris mais pas qu'à
Paris Lyon Marseille et puis
euh
également des sites
ultramarins euh qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
on a renforcé les effectifs je vais vous
donner quelques exemples il y a 164
contractuels qui seront recrutés pour
faire faire face à l'ensemble de la
hausse d'activités liées aux Jeux
Olympiques 49 magistrats en surnombre
dans les juridictions de la région
parisienne sur nombre total puisquil y a
différents sites je viens de le rappeler
de de 81 magistrats ce qui on va le dire
fait parfois raller un certain nombre de
juridictions et oui parce que on dit
mais et nous mais oui mais on a les Jeux
Olympiques à assurer faut qu'on assure
la sécurité de nos compatriotes il y a
aussi d'ailleurs tout un mouvement pas
rentrer dans le détail mais euh qui
s'est opéré grâce à la direction
d'administration pénitentiaire parce que
il y a des transférements qui sont
évidemment prévus parce que un afflux
massif de population sans aucun doute
généré aussi euh de la délinquence les
PIC
pocket les questions de
dopage la billetterie la fausse
billetterie et cetera et cetera donc on
s'attend évidemment à une si je dire une
une inflation de de de la délinquence
elle est au fond consubstantielle au
nombre de de gens qui vont se retrouver
sur les sites olympiques donc on a pris
un certain nombre de dispositions pour
qu'on ait les places dans les
établissements pénitentiaires pour
pouvoir accueillir et on va opérer un
certain nombre de transférements
notamment je je je pense quand Yve qui a
été inauguré il y a pas longtemps
j'étais avec la première ministre c'est
1000 places euh ben on fera en sor de
pouvoir transférer des gens de la région
parisienne pour que nous soyons que nous
soyons opérationnel bon pour répondre en
un mot alors avec optimisme me
direz-vous mais il y a matière à l'
parce que une fois encore on a beaucoup
travaillé la cour d'appel de Paris la
cour d'appel de Versailles tribunal
judiciaire de bobini je pense qu'on sera
prêt et que nous le sommes déjà pour
anticiper les les les Jeux
Olympiques madame Verrien vous vous vous
m'avez interr
également sur
Portalis alors j'ai constaté à mon
arrivée au ministère je suis pas le seul
à avoir fait ce
constat une dérive du projet
bon utiliser les mots qui conviennent et
on est revenu à l'objectif premier à
savoir déployer un logiciel unique pour
toute la chaîne civile et vous avez à
juste titre rappelé que ça ne concernait
pas que le pénal évidemment le le
numérique même si donné l'exemple de la
PPN parce que il est si j'ose dire à
l'avantage du ministère alors euh euh ça
permet de remplacer euh on va remplacer
h h applicatifs qui portent des noms euh
bon un peu singulier
[Musique]
euh unessi tutimine tout ça on va
simplifier tout ça euh et une première
version d'applicatif a d'orors et déjà
été déployé à titre expérimental sur
neuf
juridictions la généralisation à
l'ensemble des prudom se déroule jusqu'à
la mi 2024 ensuite ce sera le JAF il
s'agit là des deux contentieux civils
vous le savez les plus important dans la
vie de nos concitoyens le le déploiement
va aller de plus en plus
vite parce que les principaux obstacles
techniques je peux dire qu'ils ont été
euh affronter et dépasser aujourd'hui
l'avancée du projet est évidemment
décisive pour le projet zéro papier pour
l'ambition zé
papier ça
paraît quand j'ai dit ça certains ont
dit ENF quand même zéro papier les
juridictions administratives l'ont fait
donc c'est parfaitement possible de le
faire réorganisant un peu je m'inspire
souvent des juridictions administratives
et puis
on a maintenant un secrétaire général
adjoint qui s'occupe de ces questions
numériques et je pense pouvoir dire sous
le contrôle de mon directeur de cabinet
qu'on avance à pas de géant et que nous
avons fait de de de vrais progrès
ensuite vous m'avez parlé de la charge
de travail des magistrats bon et du
fameux référentiel al
d'abord vous savez que cet outil avait
été envisagé il a des temps que je
qualifie volontiers d'immémorioux et
puis il avait
été caché sous le tapis pour dire les
choses bon j'ai décidé de leessortir
j'ai décidé d'aller au bout et on a même
envisagé
d'ailleurs qu'il y ait un véritable
travail sur la charge de travail
évidemment nous préparons cela avec les
syndicats nous le faisons de façon
active parce que que les magistrats ont
à juste titre exprimé leur
désappointement leur leur désarrois les
les difficultés qui étaient les leurs
bon mais il faut quand même savoir que
l'Allemagne s'est dotée d'un tel d'un
tel
système et que la construction du
référentiel ça a mis 4 ans donc c'est
long la DJ réuni régulièrement pour le
bâtir les organisations syndicales et
c'est cette méthode cette méthodologie a
permis dès à présent d'adopter 16
référentiels pour la première instance
11 pour les fonctions du siège CIN pour
les fonctions du parquet et les travaux
sont en en voie de
finalisation pour la filière
GES et l'activité de soutien siège et
parqué avec les spécificité des chefs de
juridiction doit être examiné
prochainement donc là aussi si on on
avance la réalité c'est qu'on peut pas
se cacher derrière son petit doigt sur
des questions qui sont aussi majeures
que celle-là il faut affronter la
réalité en face bon moi je n'ai pas la
prétention de dire que ces budgets même
si il sont historiques même s'ils sont
importants et vous le soullignez toutes
et tous vont tout régler et que tout est
terminé non c'est bien sûr ce sont des
des marches qu'il conviendra de de
gravir encore tout ne sera pas réglé
d'ici 2027 mais nous sommes sur une
j'allais dire une
trajectoire pas utiliser de grand mots
mais philosophique où l'on considère
enfin la justice comme étant essentiel
il fut un temps où le budget des anciens
combattants était supérieur au budget de
la justice et on avait des augmentations
1 % du budget bon ce sont des temps
révolu et moi je dis et et moi je dis
non mais sur une
responsabilité collective mais je veux
quand même dire que le garde des saau
qui viendra et qui proposera un budget
de 1 % bonne chance non mais parce que
parce que on a tous collectivement
compris à quel point il était important
de donner à la justice des moyens
supplémentaires ça je pense que c'est
une évidence pour tout le monde et on ne
sera plus dans l'abandon humain
budgétaire et politique bon alors
ensuite madame Verrien par vous m'z
décidément posé beaucoup de questions
euh alors Tribunal des
affaires le le le Tae alors c'est en
cours expertise en cours je suis content
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
candidatures donc on concerte voilà et
cetera des parlementaires viennent me
dire régulièrement serait bien chez moi
et ca donc on est en train de regarder
regardez tout ça avec le le maximum de
de d'impartialité il faut qu'on ait des
grands tribunaux des tribunaux moyens
bon tout ça est à est à expertiser parce
que l'échéance sof fera de ma part et si
si ma mémoire ne me trahit pas c'est on
démarre
2025 bon donc c'est en cours euh voilà
et si vous avez des suggestions à me
faire
sur les les Tae vous souhaiteriez voir
implantter chez vous euh je
j'accueille tout ça avec une évidente
bienveillance bon
ensuite vous m'avez vous m'avez madame
Verrien
oui oui mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise vous êtes comme vous
l'avez dit rentré dans le vif du sujet s
sans mauvais jeu de mots he dans
d'emblé expérimentation construite à
versaill en 2022 à la demande des
instances nationales je parle des
adresses mail des juges consulaires
euh il y a eu un très faible usage du
Service 15 connexions par mois sur un
ressort de 147 juges bon alors les
échanges se poursuivent avec la DSJ et
les juges consulaires afin de d'affiner
plus précisément les besoins parce que
pas utiliser des outils enfin mettre en
place des outils dont personne ne ne ne
se sert je pense que euh ça n'est pas le
but de la manœuvre et enfin une ultime
question de madame la sénatrice Verrien
sur les rénovations énergétiques du parc
immobilier bon oui on construit et on
construit verre et on réhabilite
réhabilite vert et j'ai même demandé à
laadap euh il y a un travail qui est en
cours on a de grandes surface évidemment
de de de de la
toiture les établissements
pénitentiaires si on peut pas les
équiper
de comment s'appelle ça de capteur oh
pardon merci beaucoup madame de panneau
voil alà on m'a dit oui mais peut-être
des problèmes de sécurité ce qu'on
appelle le
grappillage pour éviter les évasions
c'est quand même le but donc on est en
train de regarder ça mais moi je
souhaite qu'on y aille parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a de grandes surfaces et
qu'on pourrait les équiper de façon
verte écologique toutes les dépenses
d'investissement dédié à la rénovation
énergétique du parc judiciaire sont en
constante augmentation depuis 2020 et la
quasi-ttalité des des des palais de
justice des tribunaux sont concernés
évidemment par l'objectif de réduction
de 40 % d'énergie d'ici
2030 fixé par décret écoÉNERGIE
tertiaire euh madame la sénatrice haribé
bon oui vous avez raison de rappeler mon
attachement au CF euh
alors je sais que les CF sont parfois
critiqués mais la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse fait un travail je ti
évidemment votre
disposition et de ce travail il ressort
et j'ai naturellement la faiblesse de
penser qu'il est objectif
que les CF
permettent une diminution de la récidive
importante parce que on va quand même
rappeler qu'il y a plus d'éducateur que
de gamins dans les CF et que donc il y a
véritablement des des soins qui sont
apportés à ces à ces
gamin
psychologique
psychiatrique sanitaire
parfois on y apprend à lire à écrire à à
faire de la mécanique voilà donc il y a
véritable investissement de la PGJ dans
les CF et je pense
que ils sont sont extrêmement utiles
évidemment évidemment on peut pas sauver
tous les gamins qui s'y trouvent mais en
sauveré quelquesuns ben voyez ça
justifie
cette cette cette institution je veux
également
vous qu'on noublie pas les centres
éducatifs renforcés et moi j'ai j'ai
toujours été favorable à un partenariat
euh protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
et militaire
parce que certains de ces gamins à
l'évidence ont besoin de l'autorité
bienveillante des militaires j'ai vu une
expérimentation à
quetquidan moi j'ai
été séduit et d'ailleurs nous allons
dans le le le volet si j'ose dire post
émeute et et et proposition on a on a
déjà beaucoup travaillé on a finalisé un
certain nombre de choses je vous le dis
accélérer ce partenariat PGJ armé voilà
euh dérive de l'impact du CJPM sur le
raccourcissement des délais de jugement
bon il est vrai que la phase antérieure
euh à l'audience de
culpabilité ne permet pas un placement
de plus de 3 mois c'est une
réalité c'était l'objectif du CJPM de
raccourcir les délais euh ensuite on
peut toujours améliorer les choses on a
là 2 ans d'expérimentation la PGJ
considère que c'est un beau texte les
juges des enfants euh
euh je crois pouvoir leur dire le le le
dire je suis pas leur porte-parole mais
je crois pouvoir dire que ce texte est
un texte
aujourd'hui très majoritairement
apprécié il a atteint son objectif de
réduction des délis enfin vous songez
qu'avant cette modification il y
avait un mineur sur deux qui était jugé
quand il était majeur ENF ça ça n'avait
mais mais mais aucun sens tout le monde
perdait son temps le message pédagogique
il arrivait euh évidemment bien trop
tard les juges des enfants se
demandaient ce qu'il faisaient là parce
que
juger un jeune homme de de de de 16 ans
quand il en a 21 soit il s'est ancré
dans la délinquence puis alors le le le
jugement du tribunal pour enfant c'est
lol quoi soit il en est complètement
sorti et et ça ne sert mais là aussi
strictement à rien c'est des énergies
perdues on n'est pas efficace bon voilà
euh euh sur sur parcours alors
euh on procède par étape et le secteur
associatif
2025 je pense que ce sera réglé il a
fallu le temps de le mettre en place
vous l'avez dit ce sont ce sont ceux qui
ont les mains dans le camboui qui ont
créé parcours et c'est son grand
avantage en réalité parce que il prend
compte évidemment des des des réalités
et ensuite
qu'est-ce que l'on a évoqué c'est à peu
près
tout peut-être je reviens
ensuite non sur ces questions je réponds
monsieur le sénateur bogel pour lui dire
que les mission réalisé par le SPIP et
notamment en milieu ouvert bon à mes
yeux sont tout aussi essentiels il y a
le milieu ouvert le milieu fermé et et
elle doit continuer à se développer et
dans le budget 2024 la dotation qui
correspond se maintiendra à un niveau
élevé supérieur à 50 millions soit 51,8
million d'euros pour être tout à fait
précis en 2024 et
53 contre
53,4 en 2023 c'est une haose de 30 %
depuis
2022 je rappelle qu'en 2022 le chiffre
c'était 39,8 million donc forte forte
progression madame la sénatrice de lâre
alors là oui il faudrait comme l'a dit
Madame de La Gonterie 3 He
quoi c'est le sujet par définition
difficile qui qui ne souffre pas la
caricature le
le Dominique
simonou me rappelle
régulièrement avec l'opiniattreté et et
le talent que je lui connait de de de
longues dates que nous avons un problème
de surpopulation carcérale et à vrai
dire cette difficulté ne m'a m'a pas
échappé non non et et et me
honte bon que que que souhaiterait
Dominique Simono souhaiterait que on
libère première solution
ouais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
monde et chaque fois que j'échange avec
elle tout à fait officiel on me dit
Nicole ou Nicole Boué Nicole Boué Nicole
Boué elle a elle elle a eu 1000 fois
raison en période covid de faire ce
qu'elle a fait enfin jeux dire il était
question de la protection de la santé
des détenus des agents pénitentiaire et
d'ailleurs il y a des agents
pénitentiaires qui sont morts de la
covid bon c'était
indispensable et moi je j'étais avocat à
l'époque je j'ai dit dans l'Express
publique que voilà qui était parfois la
mienne j'ai dit
que c'était mais plus qu'utile de faire
ça bon maintenant les choses ont un peu
changé
alors d'abord il faut assumer la
responsabilité politique de libérer des
milliers de gens aujourd'hui
bon je suis pas certain que les Français
auraient envie de cela je suis en
revanche certain que certains mouvements
très très très très à droite
bénéficierit de cela par contrecoup bon
pardon mais c'est quand même une
difficulté ensuite Dominique Dominique
Simono elle
propose des quotas des quotas je je je
m'arrache les cheveux qui me restent
parce que ça veut dire que dans dans
dans une dans un établissement
pénitentiaire qui n'est pas plein on
pourrait incarcérer à tour de bras
oui mais
att non c'est non alors là vous pouvez
pas me reprocher ça c'est pas vrai
mais je vais vous dire quelque chose
madame la sénatrice je travaille
làdessus venez me voir c'est vraiment le
moment parce que je veux faire quelque
chose mais je veux qu'on trouve les
bonnes solutions voilà et et ma porte
vous savez est ouverte bon donc vous me
dites que je suis caricaturel mais je
reprends quand même parce que c'est un
peu ça qui est exposé on me dit ben
là finalement on peut incarcérer il a de
la place mais là on n'incarcère plus ah
ouis mais excusez-moi ça pose quand même
des petites difficultés non
euh je vois pas pourquoi moilin
bénéficierait d'une Clémence à raison de
la surpopulation et l'autre pas autre
difficulté c'est que quand même ça vient
percuter l'indépendance des magistrats
qui ont décidé tel ou tel peine
bon tout
ça ça se travaille mais d'ailleurs dans
dans le dernier texte que que que le
Sénat a
voté je je rappelle que nous avons
étendu le travail d'intérêt général au
secteur
associatif donc plus de tige
naturellement le tige il est réservé à
la délinquance de basse
intensité certains font des caricatures
en disant le garde des saut est est
tobira empire et il veut qu'on
enferme un quintuple assassin et que il
subisse un tige c'est tellement débile
ridicule ça n'a aucun sens bon on est
allé sur l'arceux aussi dans le texte
que nous avons travailler
ensemble construit que vous avez
amélioré enrichi bon donc il y a ces
pistes il y a également moi je ne
voulais plus des réductions automatiques
de peine parce que je trouve que on a
rien sans rien puis que si on veut
quelque chose bah faut faut l'obtenir
quand même et pas n'importe comment et
je les ai conditionné à l'effort donc on
a considéra augmenté maintenant le
nombre d'emplois pénitentia avec vous le
savez bien précédent texte un contrat
d'emplois pénitentiaire ce qui est quand
même quelque chose d'intéressant de
novateur d'incitatif bon
donc l'autre levier moi je le dis c'est
la construction d'établissement
pénitentiaire je vais pas avoir hte de
ça ça permet d'assurer une réponse
pénale ferme bon et de régler par
ailleurs la question de la détention
indigne sur lequel nous avons eu un très
beau texte monsieur le Président la
Commission des Lois du Sénat et non
seulement les conditions indignes mais
également bien sûr la sécurité et le
confort du personnel pénitentiaire
auquel ils font songer parce que plus
les conditions sont sont dignes et plus
le personnel pénitentiaire peut mettre
en place la réinsertion tout ça bah
c'est des boucles on a développé les SAS
qui sont ces établissements vers la
sortie structure d'accompagnement vers
la sortie cœur de ville pour permettre à
des détenus de comment
dirais-je être au plus près des des
différents organismes pour pouvoir se
réinsérer trouver un boulot bah ça c'est
de la récidive en moins on a par
ailleurs mis en place la LSC elle est
votée elle est entrée dans dans dans les
murs judiciaire la LSC elle permet une
libération avec une obligation qui est
une obligation de logement quand le
relica est de 3 mois c'est-à-dire que ce
qu'on veut éviter c'est les sorties
sèches éviter les sorties sèches ça
évite naturellement la récidive voilà
des choses sur lesquelles on travaille
et le travail et ma réflexion sur ce
point n'est pas abouti et si je je le
dis bien sûr vous avez un certain nombre
d'idées à à à porter auprès de moi je
suis je suis tout à fait preneur parce
que je vais pas contrairement à ce que
vous aviez dit n'était pas prémonitoire
vous allez voir rester 2 he à expliciter
ces questions mais vraiment elles sont
complexes et comme on vit dans une
époque de qui ne connaît plus la nuance
si vous voulez voilà
euh c'est c'est difficile à régler et ça
mérite quand même que l'on s'y
attarde monsieur le sénateur boncarère
taux
d'exécution en matière informatique
euh alors j'y suis évidemment très
attentif et 100 % des crédits numériques
votés par le plement seront utilisés
pour 2023 pas mal
bah
là vous êtes obligé de de de délivrer un
petit satisfait site au ministère bon
merci monsieur le sénateur maîtrise
d'ouvrage et maîtrise d'œuvre
bon voilà le mode opératoire du deuxème
plan de transformation numérique sur
chaque projet il y a un
responsable euh
qui rapproche maîtrise d'ouvrage et
maîtrise d'œuvre internalisation des
compétences
informatiques les effectifs numériques
du secrétariat général sont passés
depuis
2017 de 450 àprès de
900 bon et en 2024 on recrutera encore
55 ingénieurs pour limiter le recours
aux prestations extérieures et les
consultations sont beaucoup plus
systématiques sur le
terrain voilà ce que je peux vous dire
il y avait je crois ah les drones
ah alors les
drones vous savez qu'on a mis on a mis
en place un site il y a longtemps
c'était quelques mois après mon arrivé
ça un un drone je Paron c'est la fatigue
un site des bonnes pratiques bon parce
que on avait constaté je vous rappelle
ça que certains procureurs dans certains
ressorts faisaient des trucs formidables
dont les gens du ressort d' côté
profiteit pas par définition donc le
choix c'était soit une circulaire par
bonne pratique soit on mettait tout ça
sur un site et les magistrats le
consultter échanger rajouter des choses
et cetera bon et on a on est allé
au-delà de nos frontières et on a un
travail qui a été réalisé par les
Italiens la pénitentiaire s'est
rapproché de l'aviation
pour essayer justement
de contrecarrer ces drones là parce que
ils ont non dans un sens bon
et c'est c'est c'est franchement
insupportable donc on a mis en place des
sécurisations qui sont importantes
notamment des des
filets sur les parkings on a aussi
sécurisé on a a fait beaucoup de choses
là-dessus il reste encore des choses à
faire puisque on apprend de temps en
temps dans la estce que on est allé
livrer en général c'est pas des biscuits
au chocolat bon donc on est très très
très très attentif et très proactif et
moi j'aimerais bien que le travail que
que l'on s'inspire là on voit d'abord la
faisabilité mais qu'on s'inspire de la
pratique italienne j'en ai parlé
d'ailleurs au ministre des des des
transports pour essayer d'avoir une
réponse ferme claire nette précise parce
que évidemment les gens ils lisent le
journal ils appellent que des types sont
livrés en produit stupéfiant par un
drone c'est quand même insupportable
quoi donc voilà il faut qu'on s'adapte
aux techniques certains s'adaptent
vite mais on a mis je peux vous donner
vous faire passer évidemment les moyens
qui ont été alloués pour sécuriser et
les personnels et les établissements
pénitenties évidemment et sont des
moyens sont des moyens
importants madame de La Gonterie
non j'ai vu vous étiez distrait làun
coup
ça alors Paul vif quel modalité bon
alors j'ai signé une circulaire alors
vous avez dit je l'ai pris pour un
compliment que on avait bien choisi le
timing voilà pour une fois que vous me
faites un compliment non mais j'en
accepte l'augure et et je suis heureux
bon alors sign une
circulaire de mise en œuvre le lendemain
de la public ition du
décret vous avez rappelé qu'il a été
publié au JO le 24 novembre entré en
vigueur 1er janvier
2024 179 chargés de mission
déployé on évoque évidemment les
conditions d'organisation des pôles et
17,2 million d'euros sont
consacrés au vif dans le budget
euh l'autre question qui est posée c'est
évidemment oui mais cette organisation
nouvelle oui je l'entends mais elle est
indispensable
euh je pense que nul ne conteste la la
très très grande qualité du travail qui
a été réalisé par nos parlementaires
dont madame dont madame Verrien euh sur
sur ces questions elles ont consulté
presque envie de dire la terre entière
se sont déplacés donc la question des
tribunaux spécialisés c'est quelque
chose qui qui qui n'a pas été retenu et
et très légitimement et d'ailleurs les
magistrats n'en voulaient pas euh ces
pôles sont indispensables ils vont se
mettre ils vont se mettre en place euh
comme comme l'a dit monsieur le sénateur
Bourgie on a déjà anticipé d'une
certaine façon puisque mais
l'anticipation d'ailleurs elle elle elle
est elle est elle est elle consiste
d'abord à se parler c'est c'est la c'est
la toute première chose à ce que les uns
et les autres ne fonctionnent plus en
silo c'està-dire que le JAF parle au
qui parle au procureur on parle
évidemment aux forces de sécurité
intérieure
enfin c'est l'antimégac si j'ose dire
qui qui a été quand
même l'antimériniaac il y a l'igj est
allé expertiser il y a pas de faute
individuelle je je je ne veux incriminer
personne en revanche il y a une espèce
de mauvais ais habitudes ou deux
mauvaises habitudes au pluriel qui font
que les uns et les autres sont pas
parlés et et et et la catastrophe est
arrivée là évidemment c'est trop tard
donc voilà et moi j'avais dit à cette
époque j'avais pris une circulaire qui
avait été qualifié de cominatoire mais
peu importe en disant les bracelets en
rapprochement vous les laissez pas dans
les tiroirs on en a maintenant on
s'enert on les utilise et cetera et
cetera bon donc voilà je pense que les
choses vont
je je pense qu'elles sont attendues par
les magistrats qui sont sensibilisés
évidemment à toutes ces questions
violence intrafamilial et qui ont
d'ailleurs reçu ça aussi c'est une des
évolutions qu'il faut qu'il faut
souligner une une formation à l' nm et
formation continue pour être au
rendez-vous de ce contentieux euh madame
madame la sénatrice Mercier le le
disposit 1 pardon que vous avez 1
c'est le Budet non c'est non c'est non
c'est le budget 24
oui non mais c'est c'est mais parce que
votre crainte si si je comprends bien
vous dites qu'est-ce qu'on a lou je vous
donne le chiffre et je dis mais l'autre
solution pour que les pôles puissent se
mettre en place parce que votre crainte
c'est qu'ils se mettent pas en place que
ce soit charge nouvelle mais c'est quand
même les personnels que l'on envoie
c'est c'est dit oui c'est ça je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure
c'est quand même les personnels qu'on
envoie ça c'est quand même la réponse à
un certain nombre de questions qui sont
posées sur la
faisibilité de nouvell politiqu comme
celle-là bien sûr que on
envoie on
envoie des magistrat des
greffiers des contractuels on m'a
d'ailleurs posé une question mais je
l'ai je l'ai oublié je sais pas qui me
l'avait posé sur l'équipe autour du
magistrat qui me l'a posé la question
c'est vous je suis
confus les magistrats les magistrats
euh ils ont
euh demander évidemment l'équipe une
équipe autour
de je l'ai dit ça les recentre sur leur
cœur de métier
puis on peut diviser le le délai de
jugement par deux parce que l'équipe
peut préparer la jurisprudence des
projets de décision et cetera et cetera
bon et c'est vrai c'est vrai moi je l'ai
constaté à plusieurs reprises dans mes
déplacements que les greffiers ont tu
une espèce de
crainte hein de la concurrence des
attachés de justice d'autant que nous
nous disions ces attachés de justice des
contractuels qui vont être cdisés qui
vont recevoir une formation qui vont
prêter servment et là les greffiers dit
mais Ben et nous légitimement et moi je
les ai euh rassuré chaque fois que j'ai
pu en disant que ils avaient une place
absolument essentielle dans cette équipe
bien sûr parce que d'abord ils ont une
connaissance de la procédure enfin
qu'elle soit civile qu'elle soit pénale
ils connaissent le magistrat avec lequel
il travaille depuis parfois longtemps
ils ont des réflexes qui sont des
réflexes judiciaires dont on ne peut pas
se passer et je je crois en tous les cas
je
l'espère et si je me trompe c'est c'est
quelque chose qui me chagrine beaucoup
mais je crois qu'ils ont été rassurés
sur la place qui serait là l'URE chaque
fois que je me suis déplacé on m'a dit
et nous et nous bon vous l'entendez
encore moi alors je dois à la vérité de
dire que je l'entends de moins en moins
parce que ben quand vous dites une fois
deux fois et puis cette équipe elle ne
va pas se constituer sans eux donc ils
vont très très vite passer de d'une
appréhension vous savez chaque fois
qu'on change les
choses c'est très humains on appréhende
un peu et qu'est-ce que mais moi je
pense que dès que cette équipe va se
mettre en place ben les greffiers il
vont constater naturellement j'allais
dire et l'adverbe me paraît bien choisi
que ils sont au cœur de cette équipe et
les choses vontont vont vont bien se
passer madame merci vous m'avez
interrogé sur le la tentative de
médiation familiale préalable
obligatoire et j'avais d'ailleurs une
une décision sur les les conc une
question sur les conciliateurs alors moi
je me tiens monsieur le Président de la
Commission des LO du Sénat je me tiens à
votre disposition pour que l'on détaille
si vous si vous le souhaitez les
dispositions réglementaires qui ont été
prises et les deux nouvelles procédures
que nous avons mis en place elles ont
pour
objectif d'abord de faire en sorte que
le justiciable se réapproprie son procès
je l'ai dit à nombreuses reprises vous
avez des procédures civiles qui touchent
à l'intime dans lequel par fois le
justiciable ne voit pas son juge mais
bon sang comment vous voulez que les
gens aiment la justice quand elle n'est
pas incarnée
bon peut pas pas procédure du divorce
par exemple ou non mais on l'a voulu
mais moi je veux pas donc pardon on l'a
voulu non
mais je vous le dis c'est quelque chose
que je porte avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme on a mis en place les
ambassadeurs de l'amiable alors il y a
euh enseignant euh professeur de droit
euh avocats
magistrat des notaires des commissaires
de justice ils vont se déplacer dans
toutes les cours d'appel pour expliciter
expliquer d'abord les deux nouvelles
procédures qu'on met en place moi je me
tiens à la disposition du Sénat pour
venir fait voilà et expliquer ce que
l'on a mis en place où on est allé
chercher ces procédures pourquoi on est
allé les chercher est-ce que c'est une
des questions alors parmi tant d'autres
est-ce que c'est un modèle économique
viable pour les avocats et la réponse à
l'évidence et oui et donc le premier
objectif c'est que le justiciable il se
réapproprie son procès sera pas
forcément content à la fin mais il se
réapproprie son procès le deuxième
objectif c'est que le juge soit au cœur
de son de son métier il y a eu tellement
de questions qui ont été évoqué par les
magistrats dans le l'expression de leur
malêtre sur qu'est-ce que l'on devient
quel est le sens de notre de notre
mission et cetera et enfin et enfin ça
va beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus vite
nous on est à 1 % de médiation et dans
les pays
anglosaxons au au Canada on est à 80 70
80 % c'est devenu un réflexe mais ça
implique un changement de paradigme que
les avocat ne soit plus forcément dans
la culture de la castagne qui soit dans
l'idée d'aller vers la médiation de se
mettre autour d'une table et d'ailleurs
de ce point de vue l'AG sera mieux payé
chaque fois que l'avocat souhaite aller
vers de la médiation et puis enfin
franchement mais les gens ils sortent
d'un procès ils ont trouvé un accord
tout le monde est content ça fait deux
comptant et aujourd'hui ça fait jamais
de contents même s'ils sont modérément
contents
évidemment évidemment mais aujourd'hui
ça fait ind déçu et un content donc il y
a un type sur deux qui trouve que la
justice ça pas bien marché soit qu'il a
pas eu le bon juge soit qu'il a pas eu
le bon avocat parfois les deux donc
voilà quand on veut améliorer le lien de
confiance entre nos compatriotes et la
justice et qu'on voit les sondages sur
la justice B il y avait aucune raison
qu'on se prive de ça donc que je voilà
donc
conciliateur médiateurs il nous sont
absolument
indispensables le
tmfpo est un
dispositif ah zut bah vous lui direz
monsieur le Président est un dispositif
expérimental et les résultats ne sont
pas encore clairs donc j'ai prolongé
l'expérimentation pour quelques années à
périmètrre Constant voilà monsieur le
sénateur
Marc il est parti aussi vous
transmettez bon en fait en fait la
question c'était l'attractivité de la
DAP sur les 162 recrutements non
effectués par rapport à l'obj 2022 149
ça c'est
important consommation consommation sont
imputable à l'administration
pénitentiaire au titre des personnels de
surveillance parce que le métier de
surveillant pénitentiaire c'est un
métier difficile qui souffre on sa tous
d'un manque d'attractivité et c'est
exactement la raison pour laquelle j'ai
annoncé le 21 février dernier quià
compté du 1er janvier à venir le corps
des surveillants péniten passera de B en
a et je dois dire et je dois dire parce
que c'est vrai que c'était une
revendication porté par les personnels
pénitentiaes depuis plus de 20
ans et
enfin une monsieur le sénateur Bourgie
ouais alors non ben non mais c'est moi
fait aucun commentaire voilà je vous
remercie socip la socialo sa
gripe bon pas de commentaire no comment
DSJ + 36 % plus 36 % pour la DSJ
monsieur le monsieur le sénateur et on
passe de 2,8 million d'€ en 2020 à 3,8
millions en
2024 priorité là au service
judiciaire milliards pardon milliards ah
oui milliard ouis c'est la valce des
zéros chant chant Chantz Jacques Bress
je me suis un peu perdu milliards
milliards oui ah oui oui je vous voyez
d's de Liné je je je vous voyz sceptique
et circonspect je voilà
milliards toujours
toujours merci monsieur le ministre de
d'avoir répondu à l'ensemble de ces
questions sur un débat fourni euh je
donc lever la séance et vous souhaitez à
toutes et à tous une excellente soirée
merci monsieur le
président